hey everyone I'm Liana Galera and Ichi
is coming at you live from Comic Con
with three of the stars from The Walking
Dead hey guys happy Comic Con to you
thank you so much for taking time out of
your crazy con weekend to come sit down
with us
congratulations mr. berry first Comic
Con is it a lot to take in
yeah doesn't actually really busy
meeting everybody when you guys have
such an amazing panel yesterday we now
know that the Walking Dead is coming out
on October 6
yeah our first look at an unbelievable
season 10 trailer what was it like for
you guys to be able to see such a long
trailer it wasn't really working hard
for such a long time yeah there's a lot
of shockers in there you have a certain
female friend of mine kissing a king
which kind of pisses Darrell off a bit
we got a really good bad guy this season
there's a lot going on right yeah
there's a lot but that was my first time
seeing each other yeah and that was your
first Hall H panel
yes was a lot yeah she was the most
professional one up on that stage I
asked her a question and she man
straight off just like unsetting yeah
exactly like on set she knows her lines
and our lines better than we do okay I
gotta know what are these guys like on
set oh yes like it's not well yeah but
good try
but so here's the thing here we go
there's a swear jar but people don't
want to pay so there's a full word cost
different amounts that's how it was in
the beginning and then people got mad
because
especially dance because I was like I
would always hang out with him and like
off of set and then he would save so
many things and then he didn't want to
pay and so now there's only certain
words and they all cost the same to only
they're really bad Chandler did the same
thing just wedge' yeah it would pay for
college if we paid up and she could
retire yeah there's no way I'm paying I
I mixed events later day to day two I
was like that we can't do this anymore
let's talk about season ten you're
gearing up for a whispers war just a bit
of a tongue twister why is this gonna be
unlike any other battle we've seen on
The Walking Dead oh it's different
there's it's there's a whole theme of
paranoia this year because you don't
know who's who and it's starting to
cause a rift within the groups on who
you can trust and their spies it's a
whole creepy way of doing things this
year what that's a swear dollar Meighan
actually gets you get out of his cell
this year's legs a little bit about that
you know I remember last year at the
beginning of the season Angela the
showrunner and I talking about you know
the a year in the cell and I thought at
the time oh this would be cool well
maybe this will be as an actor this is
gonna be quite a way to go and then
after like midway through the season I
was going crazy I literally was going
stir-crazy so to get out again and
act with some people has been it's good
for me and Megan okay lead Judith is
such a little firecracker just like
yourself but I'm curious to know what
are your favorite types of scenes to
shoot do you like the action scenes the
more emotional scenes I like to kill
walkers and you're very good at them
it's kind of like you have to make up
[Music]
need to get you like a signature weapon
just calm she's gotta choose between one
a bullet a bullet or you're kind of
running that a bullet yeah excuse 20
barrels we're about to see when you shot
me it was the one thing cuz yeah yeah
negan doesn't shut up so it was like
four minutes of her - just put it down
actually
but most of the time you're the most
picked up girl answered I gotta say her
like amazing one of my favorite things
about the trailer was so much Carol and
Daryl goodness in it
fly the ship bracelets I felt like my
heart was gonna explode how does it feel
knowing that you got to have so many
seeds and fullness of this year I mean
there's so many die-hard care of their
about their you know that I mean that
scene was a very sweet scene but I got a
Melissa's lovely but carol has been a
real pain in my butt for Daryl this
season I will say is what I sweat word I
swear yeah pain in my butt yes thank you
thank you but it's I love working with
Melissa she's she's dynamite we have
such a good rapport and we're good
friends and we have fun see for me when
Ezekiel and deny kiss I was like this no
I thought it opened the door for you and
Carol I don't know if it's this year but
um because like I say she's a little bit
Craig gray this year but I mean you know
never say never but I don't know she's
she's a problem your two besties in here
right now we have your on screen bestie
Kayla claim Judith and then we have your
off-street investing so we're gonna play
the besties friend okay if your bestie
was hungry on set what would you bring
him person have to find you like you
just want I was gonna say skittles okay
so maybe seem to me Jane fonder
no you haven't when your best seat when
you can't find your bestie in between
takes on set what is he usually doing
Taylor yeah
chillin - trailer or he'll sit down
music and to learn more lives
lastly what is your favorite part about
working with your bestie its motorcycle
lane will teach I'm not working more me
to Saturday we have nice chemistry but
will we get to see a little bit more of
a crossover between vegan and Darrell
because they've had a little bit of a
head-butting relationship but I feel
like they might need to put their past
aside and come together this year I
think that I think that's the direction
that we could be heading I think the
whispers are an enemy that all hands on
deck and I think that Darrell recognizes
that and and I think that the the these
two characters may find a little bit of
common ground within within this world
which is kind of fun but just able to
work with him this year it's been a long
time and we've never really worked
together so to have a couple scenes
together it has been a joy hashtag
diggin diggin yeah maro half state
sounds like a big uns better than the
again and then we just want Judas to be
friends with everyone so that's what
I've written
oh yeah it's really rocks yeah this is
great
thank you guys so much moving down with
me I really appreciate it thank you so
much Walking Dead fans for watching keep
it locked
ET from delightful Comic Con the rest of
the day
you
[Music]